If you buy a clock like this,
one that says "radio controlled",
you just put a battery in, and it
sets itself to the correct time.
And it stays there, automatically,
for a year or more.
So it can't be receiving
signals from satellites,
there's no wifi connection,
there's nowhere near enough power
in here for that.
Instead, it uses
much older technology.
Here at the radio transmission
station in Anthorn,
the National Physical Laboratory, NPL,
broadcasts a time signal to the UK
in a simple enough format that
the cheap electronics inside
this clock can understand it,
and run accurately for over a year
on a single double-A battery.
And at NPL's base in London,
I asked their team how it all works.
- What we have in Anthorn are some
very high-end cesium atomic clocks,
like the ones we have down here.
We broadcast from there,
we monitor the signals at NPL
and accordingly put out steers to those
clocks to correct for any any change.
It's a very low frequency,
60 kilohertz,
it has very low susceptibility
to atmospheric effects.
We steer from NPL based on measuring
what Anthorn is broadcasting
at the level of nanoseconds.
That is a nanosecond, the distance light
travels in one nanosecond, 30 centimeters.
All that is taken into account.
- So that seemed simple enough.
The official timescale is kept in London.
I wasn't allowed anywhere near
the official atomic clocks,
I don't even know if they're actually
at NPL's headquarters or not,
they might be somewhere else.
They told me nothing!
But up north here, this transmitter
has separate atomic clocks,
about four hundred kilometres
away from the base.
Or 1.4 light-milli-seconds away.
There's a light-speed delay, a latency,
of about a thousandth of a second
between the transmitter here
and the base in London.
Because the team at NPL know exactly
what that delay should be,
they can issue corrections if
these clocks start to drift,
even by nanoseconds,
billionths of seconds.
Officially, the accuracy is much
lower than that, of course,
partly because they keep
a very wide safety margin,
and partly because I can introduce
a one-nanosecond drift to this clock
by doing that.
- What is really important when you're
transferring time is not about the latency,
but understanding the latency.
So you can take that out of the equation.
From the NPL, we disseminate to
the UK over radio broadcast.
Essentially that offers
the entire UK mainland
several milliseconds of
traceability to UTC.
We also have a fibre-delivered service
for regulatory compliance
in the finance sector,
guaranteed at the microsecond.
And that's fine, I can understand all that.
But then that leads to another question:
how does NPL know if their clocks
in London start to drift?
Sure, they've got many of them,
they cross-check,
and a "second" in the 21st century
is defined
by the number of vibrations
of a cesium atom.
But still, they can't be perfect.
They're meant to show
the international standad,
UTC, coordinated universal time,
so what if NPL's official source of
timekeeping truth drifts from that standard?
- UTC or coordinated universal time,
as the name suggests,
is coordinated globally, contributing
data from multiple atomic clocks
to generate what is
the global timescale, UTC.
What we have here at NPL is
the UK's timescale, UTC(NPL).
We have a whole suite of atomic clocks,
cesium clocks, hydrogen masers,
and a cesium fountain.
The Bureau of Weights and Measures
based in France
take the data from the
clocks around the globe,
and inform each of the national labs
how offset it is from UTC.
- And that's where the buck stops.
In Paris.
Unless you start getting into
physics and relativity and light cones,
and that's way beyond me.
Why does it matter?
Well, first of all, finance
and high-frequency trading.
But also: science.
Things like the Square Kilometre Array,
a planet-wide array of radio telescopes
that's being planned and built now.
When they're listening for incredibly
faint radio waves from space,
all the telescopes around the globe
have to be synchronised
with that level of precision, or the
whole experiment could fall apart.
So then, I had a final question:
when accurate timecode is being
sent from so many places,
when the public can get time
that's more than accurate enough
for almost every purpose
from navigation satellites in space:
why is this signal still important?
And the team from NPL had a rather serious answer.
- Time really is an invisible utility.
It underpins our digital infrastructure,
whether it's the synchronization
of the energy grid,
or the telecom networks, or finance.
We are so dependent on GPS
and other constellations.
One of the problems we face is
those signals are easily disrupted.
It's the equivalent of
a light bulb on the moon.
One of the things we're
doing at the NPL
is to ensure that the UK is
resilient for the future.
- Standing by the ocean
with a domestic appliance.
The weird thing is,
it's not the first time.